[موسيقى]
مرحبًا
، هذا صحيح جدًا عادةً عندما
أتحدث إلى
أشخاص لا أحب الدخول في
أشياء تقليدية لا أحب التحدث عن
شيء ممل
أو نمطي أو حتى آمن ،
فأنا دائمًا ما أبحث عن فرصة
علمية  يفكرون ويخبرونك
أن الخطوة
الأولى للتفكير علميًا هي أن أسأل لماذا
في وضعي أنا أسأل ما الذي
بدأت أفكر فيه
عما سأتحدث عنه لذلك بدأت
أفكر وتوصلت إلى استنتاج مفاده أن موضوعي اليوم
سيكون عن الحزن
كلمة الحزن نفسها مريرة جدًا ،
إنها ثقيلة ولسنا هنا لننكرها في الواقع ،
نحن لسنا هنا حتى للحديث عن
السلبية التي تجلبها
أنا هنا لأتحدث بالفعل عن
الجانب الإيجابي منه
إذا أخذنا  انظر إلى العنوان الذي
يطلق عليه اسم الجانب العلوي من الحزن
الحزن نفسه هو كلمة ثقيلة
الحزن الوحدة والعواطف
الشديدة تنفجر كل شيء يتلخص
في كلمة واحدة
وتفقد كل شيء بينهما إنها
فجوة
هي كلمتي الرئيسية عن خسارة اليوم
كيف نتعامل مع ذلك  الخسارة و  كيف
نحولها إلى
نوع من مبدأ المكافأة ،
مكسب شخصي ، تطور
مؤخرًا في مدريد في كثير من الأحيان
، وكانوا حزينين لأنهم مروا
بموت شخصي
للغاية كان حميميًا للغاية ، لقد كان أمرًا صعبًا للغاية
وبصراحة كان شخصًا قريبًا جدًا
منهم
كان ملكًا لهم  أمي رأيت
صديقي المفضل يفقد والدته منذ خمسة أشهر
بسبب السرطان ، وربما يوافق أي شخص في هذه الغرفة
على
أن أحد أكثر حالات الوفاة التي تؤثر على
أي شخص
هو أحد الوالدين ، وخاصة الفتاتين
، فلنفكر في
ذلك على أنه  قصة
لأنه من خلال ما رأيته وتعلمته
في حياتي ،
علينا أن نقول إنها مجرد دليل
، ثم تركنا النظرية تدرك
قبل خمسة أشهر فقدت صديقتي والدتها
بسبب السرطان
وعلى مدار الوقت لاحظت
أنها  لم تتغير فقط
ولكنها تناقضت مع
ما نؤمن به ، ولكن إذا كنا نسعى حقًا
ونطالب بالتعرض ، فنحن
نقول إننا نريد لأطفالنا
ويجب ألا نخاف من التعامل معهم فقط ،
ما أريدكم أن تفكروا به اليوم
هو  إيريس من العديد من
القصص ، تجميع لكيفية وصف
الحوادث
التي ستكون بمثابة مظلة ضخمة
تلقائيًا كنت هناك لدعمها
وتصفح الأمر برمته مع
مرحبًا ،
نعم الحزن والموت بشكل عام تجربة مريرة جدًا
وليست لطيفة إنها ليست كذلك  ممتع
خاصةً إذا كنت صغيرًا جدًا ،
لكن ما تعلمته منها
خلال الأشهر الماضية
هو شيئان أحدهما
أن الحزن أمر لا مفر منه ، كل شخص في
هذه الغرفة لديه فرصة 100
لحدوثه لهم
أو لشخص يعرفونه شخصيًا وهم
تهتم
والمفهوم الثاني الذي أريد أن
أتركه في أذهان الجميع اليوم
كخلاصة هو
أن الحزن يمكن أن يمنحك الحياة بدلاً من
تجريدك منها ،
لذا عد إلى القصة عندما فقدت والدتها
يوميلازا توقف عن
الأجنبية
وقالت إنها خفيفة للغاية-  من القلب فقط
بابتسامة ،
فإن أول شيء يمكن أن أفكر فيه في الواقع
هو أنها حولت شيئًا
حساسًا إلى مزحة
لم أكن مثلها في الواقع ، لقد وجدت الدعابة
في موقف نعم هو خمسة  مرارة
ولكن هذا لا يعني أنها في حالة إنكار أو
صدمة أو لا تهتم بالأمر
فهي تبحث عن
طريقتها الخاصة لجعلها أخف
وزناً وأكثر قبولاً لاحقًا
وكانت هي التي تريحهم وكانت
هي التي تطمئنهم
و  هذا عندما علمت
كما قلت أن الحزن أو الموت
عملية متقلبة
للغاية وهي كلمة غريبة إنها مريرة
وثقيلة لا معنى لها خاصة
[موسيقى]
إنها غير ملموسة لا يمكنك رؤيتها يمكنك
فقط الشعور بها وهي كذلك
يبدو الأمر منطقيًا لأي شخص في أي عمر ،
لذلك بدأت أسأل نفسي إذا كنت
سأراقبها ،
فأنا بحاجة إلى التفكير في الأمر بطريقة غير منحازة ،
وأردت أن أنظر إليه
من وجهة نظر غير منحازة للغاية ،
لذلك بدأت في التفكير وهذا هو
سؤالي الأول
بالإضافة إلى الدعم العاطفي الطبيعي
الذي نسعى إليه من الناس ،
ماذا لو قمنا بتضمين العلم في
المعادلة ،
ماذا لو أعطانا شخص ما هاجام هو
دليل إرشادي
يغير المراحل التي
تمر بها
وهذا أمر منطقي في الواقع أنا أمر
به  واحد اثنان ثلاثة أنا ذاهب من
النقطة (أ)
إلى النقطة (ب) ومن المنطقي
ذلك عندما أجريت ما أقوم به بشكل أفضل في
البحث
في فنزويلا ، فأنا أحب الأشياء التي لها
معنى
مرتبطة ببعضها البعض ويمكنني بالفعل أن
أرى أنها
تحدث أمامي لذلك أتيت  عبر
بحث أُجري
في عام 1999 ، يُطلق عليه
نموذج العملية المزدوجة للتغلب على الفجيعة
الجدال والتشجيع الفعلي للناس
على إيقاف عواطفهم وأدمغتهم ،
فلن تركز على حالة الحزن
التي ستركز على كل شيء
خارج الحزن الآن إذا ألقينا نظرة فاحصة
في النموذج ismu ، العملية المزدوجة
التي لديك عملية أ والعملية ب ،
قالت نظريتهم أنه عندما تحزن
على وفاة شخص ما ، فإنك تدخل بين
عمليتين ، الأولى تسمى الخسارة الموجهة
والثانية تسمى الاستعادة
الموجهة نحو
الخسارة تتحدث عن نفسها
وكلاهما  افعل في الواقع
الكلمة الأساسية هي الخسارة ، إنها الموت
نفسه ، والمأساة ، وفقدان المشاعر ،
كل ما
تشعر به ، والجزء الآخر يسمى الاستعادة
الموجهة ، وهذا هو المكان  تستعيد
النظام الطبيعي والاستقرار ،
وهنا تبدأ في التركيز على
المهام الثانوية
التي تركز على أي شيء
خارجها ولا تنكر حقيقة أن
الموت قد حدث
ولكنك تخطو خارج الإسلام
الذي هو الخسارة.  الجزء
الذي يمكنك قبوله ، يمكنك في الواقع
الترحيب به وعدم الشعور بالثقل
لأن هناك جانبًا آخر من
الطيف ،
استخدم هؤلاء العلماء كلمة تسمى
تذبذب
التذبذب كما نرى هي النقطة المشتركة
بين العمليتين ،
وهذا ما نفعله نتأرجح فيه  وخارج
هاتين الدائرتين ، نركز على العمق
ولكننا في نفس الوقت نتصالح معه
وكانت هاتان العمليتان الرئيسيتان
اللتان شرحا في نظريتهما
الآن بعيدًا عن العلم ، بدأت
أفكر جيدًا ،
فأنا أعرف نظرية الآن
ولكن  لم يكن تطبيقه دقيقًا
تمامًا ، لم يكن تفسيرًا ملموسًا ،
فإن
صديقي هي في الأصل كاتبة ، لذا
فهي تجدد نفسها تلقائيًا من خلال
الكتابة والكلمات واللحن.  ies
وهذه نقطة مشتركة واحدة لدينا
وهذا هو السبب في أنني أقدر الأغنية حتى
أن الأغنية تسمى فيينا من قبل بيلي جويل
في عام 1917
وهي القصة الأكثر أهمية بيلي
جويل من أدان
صحته العقلية في مرحلة ما من أجل
الوصول إلى هدف
ينجح  شطب شيئًا آخر من
قائمته ،
ومن المفارقات
أنك متعجرف جدًا بالنسبة لنا ، فأنت
أذكى جدًا بالنسبة لنا ، فأنت لا تعرف كيف تجري
محادثة سخيفة
لم تهدر أيًا من وقتها أبدًا ، ولكن
هناك نقطة
شعرت فيها بأنها كانت كذلك.  في أدنى مستوياتها
واعترفت بأن ذلك
كان أصعب بكثير من سماعها فعليًا
من شخص آخر ،
لذلك عندما أرسلت لي الأغنية مرة أخرى ،
قمت بعمل أفضل
بحث قمت به وقرأت بعضًا من قصة
الأغاني التي
كان بيلي جويل يستشهد بها في الواقع
بنصيحة والده  قدمته له ومن
المفارقات أن نفس النصيحة
كانت صديقتها المقربة ومثل
الدعم العاطفي الذي تقدمه كل أم ،
أخبرتها أمها أن تبطئ من سرعتها
وتهدئتها قبل أن
تحترق ،
فنحن لا نعرف بالفعل القيمة  من
الجملة حتى نشعر بالدهشة
من تأثيرها
أو نفقد الشخص الذي
يعطي النصيحة التي
هي هنا ويمكنني أن أشعر بها وكانت
محقة في
أن قصتها تُروى من شخص
آخر والخطوة الأولى
عندما  تحدث اليوم عن المضي قدمًا
وعدم المضي قدمًا مع الحزن
هو أنه يمكنك إيجاد وإنشاء
الدعم الذي اعتدت الحصول عليه من شخص
ما من مكان آخر
لأنه لا يوجد ضغط كافٍ في ثقافتنا ،
فأنت تعتمد فقط على الوجود المادي
ولا يجب عليك
كل ما قدمه هذا الشخص أو قدمه
في حياته
لاحقًا ، بدأنا في مناقشة هذا
معًا في
أوهايو وبدأنا في البحث على
مدار الأشهر عن
كيفية نموها وتوصلنا إلى
استنتاج
بدأنا نفكر فيه كنقطة سوداء
إذا نظرنا جميعًا  في السطر الثاني ،
هذه هي الخسارة ، هذه هي النقطة ، إنها
نقطة التحول ،
حيث يمكنك إما السماح لها
بالتعامل
معك والتحكم فيك وإخراجك عن حياتك أو
يمكنك الذهاب معها وقبولها
الجزء الموجود على اليسار هو ما تعتقده جميعًا
أنه يمكنك تقليص حجم
الموت وآثاره وكل ما
يفعله في
حياتك وتعتقد في الواقع أن هذا
سيجعل المشكلة تختفي ولكنها لا
تزال موجودة  إذا لم تكن
حريصًا بما يكفي حيال ذلك ، فسوف تدرك
لاحقًا في حياتك أن
ما فعلته هو الجانب الأيمن
لم تنكر
أنها لم تكن في حالة صدمة لم
تقاومها لم ترفض
ذلك  هناك ولا يزال موجودًا ، ولكن
بدلاً من
ذلك توسعت فيه
لاحقًا على
kabint وحتى إذا كنا سنكون
محايدين بين الجنسين ،
فلا أحد يطالب حقًا بالحق في
الانهيار بمفرده
كما لو كان سامًا ، فهو غير صحي ، لا لا
يجب أن تكون مع الناس
إنه شيء شخصي ، دعني أكون وحدي
، أرادت أن تكون بمفردها وأن تتمتع بهذه
الحرية
لاحقًا عندما بدأت في التساؤل عن
التداعيات وأنت مثال رائع لكثير من
الناس ثم بدأت تخبرني
في الأزارية ،
لا أعتقد أي شيء  منا قد
فكر في أنه يسمى الاستقبال  الموقف التدريجي
الذي تختاره كيف تريد أن تتلقى
المشكلة بالطريقة التي تريدها أن
تقودك في حياتك والطريقة التي
تدرك بها
المشكلة وموت شخص ما أو أي مشكلة في
هذا الشأن ستؤثر على الطريقة التي تختار
أن تعيش بها
حياتك  إنكار أنك لا تقوم
بمعالجته ،
أنا أفعل ذلك بشكل مختلف ،
لقد نشأت من قبل أمي ، أنا نسخة طبق الأصل
منها ،
أسعى للحصول على السعادة في الحياة وكان هذا
هو دافعهم
كما قلت
إنها لا تعرف  كيف تصاب بالاكتئاب هي
لا تعرف كيف تجعل أي شيء يثقل كاهلها
وهي لا تفعل ذلك لأنها
تريد أن تكون رائعة بقدر ما
تريد القيام بهذا
النموذج الذي يحتذى به لو أنها تريد من الناس
تكوين رؤيتهم الخاصة ،
نعم الحزن هو  هناك ترويض ، نحن لا
ننكر أنه
ابتكر وصفتك الخاصة لأنه يأخذ بعض
الوقت من التراجع ، اقرأ البحث ، فهذا
ليس مسيئًا
لأنه إذا كنت تفكر
علميًا فأنت في الواقع
منطقي وهذا هو الهدف منه لأنه في
مرحلة
ما  على وشك المجيء أو قد حدث
بالفعل  حدث أننا فقدنا جميعًا شخصًا
والمهمة الأساسية هنا هي
معرفة متى وإذا كان بإمكانك أن تعيش حياتك
بمفردك إذا لزم الأمر ،
إذا كان بإمكانها في وقت ما مشاركة
قصتها والخروج بها ، فقد أخبرتني أنه لا
أريد التوقف للحصول عليها لأن
قصتي لم تنته بعد
ولا تزال مستمرة وما زالت جديدة
ولا يزال لدي الكثير لأمره ، لذا
بدلاً من
ذلك أخبرتني أنه عندما حدثت الوفاة
وإذا كنت سأشارك هذه القصة ،
يجب أن أقول
شيئًا واحدًا  إنها النهاية وهي
البداية
ويجب ألا تدعها تخرج عن مسارها ،
يجب أن تختار الطريقة التي تريد
استلامها ، يجب أن تتحكم بها
ويجب أن تتعلم كيف تتقبلها
صديقي أرسل لي صورة
للأشهر الخمسة الماضية  حول كيفية
شفائها
من كيفية تمجيد علاقتها بوالدها
وتكثيفها للغاية ، ما الذي سأقدمه
لهم والأماكن التي ذهبت إليها
لأولئك الذين لم يلاحظوا بعد هذه
الفتاة هي في الواقع
أنا وهذه قصتي ، شكرًا لك